you wrote a review of Alan dershowitz's
new book yes on Donald Trump the title
of that book is get Trump the threat to
civil liberties due process and our
constitutional rule of law can you
summarize this book and your review of
it yes by the way I co-authored it with
my research assistant who's sitting
right here Emily yes
um and um
I thought that the book was another
example
of the fact that everybody is entitled
to a defense
and that Allen's um being involved with
Trump was purely professional it was not
political it was not philosophical
and I thought that the fact that he was
being um
uh criticized he was being shunned
because of his connection I found it
very interesting
that this is a guy who represented such
um
a call of distasteful figures
as Klaus fambulo
as
Mike Tyson
uh as uh O.J Simpson
a Sheldon Siegel
uh when he was considered to be
a skillful
lawyer made his reputation
and then he represents Donald Trump who
to my knowledge never killed anybody
um
and he's suddenly shunned I thought the
hypocrisy of it the political preening
it was a very distasteful to me
um and it was not only because he was my
friend if he wasn't my friend I think
I'd have the same view
um the holier than thou nonsense
uh the hypocrisy of it
um you know they wouldn't talk about
Martha's Vian now
alanized different I'm not so sensitive
I'm someone doesn't want to talk to me
it's no problem no problem at all
um but Alan is because considering how
controversial his life has been is
someone sensitive he's somewhat
sensitive and I've heard of telling out
you know the hour don't let it get to
you okay I can relate I can I can
definitely relate take an awesome
controversial conversation still wear my
heart on my sleeve it hurts all of it
hurts yep but maybe the pain makes you a
better
a student of human nature yep maybe
that's the case for him nevertheless the
book has a makes a a complicated and I
think an interesting point he opens the
pair he opens the book with not that
Donald Trump has announced his candidacy
for a re-election as president the
unremitting efforts by his political
opponents to quote get him to stop him
from running at any cost will only
increase these efforts May pose the most
significant threat to civil liberty
since McCarthyism so is he right he's
absolutely right because these attempted
for example the prosecution the the one
prosecution that has been brought now
Alvin Brigg in in the Manhattan
I have looked at that and I don't
believe that Trump has committed a crime
and yet Bragg was pressured to bring
that people in his office we're
threatening to quit if he didn't indict
holy and proper holy unethical
um and is going to lose the case
has Trump committed crimes yes most of
their tax crimes
um if his uh he has cheated on taxes his
whole career as far as I can tell
he could easily be indicted for the
state and federal taxes but those that
they're not as sexy
and um I think that um he's become a
Target
um by ambitious politicians ambitious
prosecutors
he has gotten some sympathy
which he doesn't deserve and um
a lot of it is is you've pardoned the
phrase political correctness the better
people are not supposed to be trumpers
um I I I had an interesting experience
about Trump I had two interesting
experiences
the more recent one was I was in the
house of um
Lauren Summers the former president of
Harvard
who is driven out by political
correctness by the way he insulted women
biologists
um I was in his house when he was still
president of Harvard
uh when the Trump Hillary Clinton
contest
took place
and I was with Elsa
um we were invited to Summer's house
in Brookline
and um
it looked like Hillary was going to win
and the Harvard faculty members they
were all celebrating they were all
figuring out what their cabinet
positions were going to be blah blah
blah blah
and then about 11 30 at night all of a
sudden it was announced in in terms of
electoral votes Trump had just geeked
out of a victory that Hillary beat him
in the popular vote but he had won the
Electoral College
and there was immediate depression
and um
like a quiet over the room the room
moved him absolutely stolen salad
and they they were all uh you know
disappointed
well that was a memorable moment and it
it told me that
they were a little bit too overconfident
and they they were savoring
being part of a presidential
Administration
uh ambition had been thwarted uh I'm not
a great fan of preening ambition I think
it blinds people to realities and the
resulting arrogance from such ambition
and the arrogance yes it's one of the
reasons I didn't accept Jim vorenberg's
offer to be part of the academic
Community I mean I represent professors
I have friends who are professors I
represent students I have friends who
are students
um and uh I have a great regard for
universities in higher education
um but I was not about to become part of
a culture I thought that it was not good
for me and not good for the institution
either that can a culture that can breed
arrogance yes self-importance yeah
and I in a sense the election of Donald
Trump was a big Fu to such correct which
is why I think he why I think he he
managed to uh to pull it off